route par route village par village ces
soldats ukrainien tentent de s'approcher
de personnes contrôlées par les russes
une contre offensive d'envergure vient
d'être lancé c'est une opération très
importante est planifiée pour détruire
les dépôts arrière pour détruire les
positions de l'ennemi les postes de
commandement et les unités militaires
selon un conseiller du président et
lenski les forces du crédit et non
percer les défenses russe le long de la
ligne de front carson est tombé dès le
premier jour de l'invasion depuis leur
oubli est devenu la monnaie officielle
et des passeports russes ont été
distribuées aux habitants pour le
président ukrainien ce n'est qu'une
question de temps avant que la ville ne
redevienne ukrainienne
journée si l'armée russe veut survivre
il est temps pour les soldats russes de
fuir de rentrer chez eux les occupants
doivent savoir que nous les chasserons
jusqu'à notre frontière jusqu'à notre
frontière dans la ligne n'a pas changé
et les occupants le savent bien
selon moscou la contre attaque
ukrainienne a été un échec et les
militaires d'ukrainiens aurait subi de
lourdes pertes